hey youtubers it's Charlie so finally my
agents of shield episode 2 video so much
awesome stuff happening this week and
again Fitz is like the repeat top
performer in the episode he is killing
it in this first couple of episodes
Marvel also just confirmed ant-man -
it's gonna be ant-man in the wasp and
they have a couple untitled films that
they just put on the board so I'm gonna
talk about that after shield stuff so be
sure to stick around to the end of the
video but getting to show stuff just
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet starting with
top 5 WTF moments number 5 we find out
what may has been doing this whole time
she has been hanging out with her father
who looks like his estranged from her
mother who is also pretty hilarious if
you look at this from a Joseph Campbell
perspective hero's journey may is just
like refusing the call so obviously now
we can start to find out what her arc is
gonna be this season we don't quite know
that yet they haven't spelled that out
she's kind of like a big sister figure
to Skye but she also isn't super hot on
the idea of all these Inhumans I would
say you like in terms of people inside
shield and inside team Coulson that like
Inhumans and people that don't like them
I would say she's closer to Mack Mack
doesn't hate them either but he sounds
like he really doesn't want to have
anything to do with them if he doesn't
have to I'd be amazed if you didn't
recognize the actor that played May's
father he shows up so many times he's
like a comedy ninja he just shows up for
a little while out of nowhere is
hilarious and then just vanishes into
the night he does a lot of voiceover
work - probably the last biggest thing
that you recognized him from is from
Kung Fu Panda
he played Poe's father the duck father I
just love the idea that Mae Special
Agent comes from a family of special
agents even though you wouldn't know it
just from looking at her father but a
really interesting pattern is formed
here we know what Mae does now when she
is just completely fried as a human
being she goes back and hangs out with
her parents
his badasses of the cavalry is she is
still a human isn't isn't that what most
people would do like when their life
just completely crumbles around them
like they don't know what to do they're
like okay I'm just gonna go stay with my
parents for a few days I could talk
about Mae all day including the fact
that she looks younger than the
20-somethings on the show despite the
fact that Mina is pushing 50 like that's
how amazing she looks but on to number
four another missing character comes
back Ward is back and he needs a ton of
cash enter new character from the Whedon
verse you definitely heard right this is
Baron von Strucker son
remember he was killed during Avengers
age of Ultron he sounds really American
even though his father's European so I'm
guessing he was just raised abroad the
way he explains it
he knew his father was a part of Hydra
but he wasn't allowed to participate in
any Hydra shenanigans don't you just
love how Ward plays on his daddy issues
to bring him to the dark side your
father's seat at the table now belongs
to you reach out and take it like that's
why he told him to kill that other
hydrogen he's like go ahead take it it's
yours do it do the thing it's a great
story arc I really hope that it pans out
I think we'll find out by the mid-season
finale usually that's when they
course-correct like before the back half
like if things don't pan out they try to
leave room to adjust the story so it's
like if this actor if the storyline that
goes nowhere
they can kill him off if they want but
this actor is actually from Joss
Whedon's much ado about nothing he was
one of the younger actors in that of
course the Whedon verse very big very
famous for raising new talent out of
obscurity Nathan Fillion probably the
best example of that so jr. von strucker
now firmly embedded with shield via the
psychiatrist at his school the Blair
characters interesting I do like the
idea of shows psychoanalyzing themselves
as long as it doesn't get too literal
but just think of him is like a
narrative device for the show to comment
on itself like as he's psycho analyzes
the characters he's actually
psychoanalyzing the direction that shows
going the biggest part of that are these
secret warriors and yes he he totally
mentioned the name secret warriors but
they said that they were doing secret
warriors a long time so it's like that
Family Guy joke where you know Peters
pointing at the screen it's like oh they
said the name of the movie in the movie
they did the thing I got a hijack my
number 3 WTF moment for that product
placement though that Jaguar ad they did
in the middle of the episode that was
total product placement some of you guys
might have picked up on that too if Yuri
watch it listen to Ward's speech he's
basically describing a really awesome
car like they want you to buy the Jaguar
it's an f-type it's actually pretty cool
car we need a new image the funny thing
is is that during the Super Bowl they
did a big Jaguar ad with a bunch of
British actors Tom Hiddleston was one of
them it was like a Jaguar villains at it
was a joke about how really
stereotypical big British villains loved
Jaguars because they're obsessed with
power
it's totally sinister so of course it's
appropriate that they would use Hydra to
create product integration for the show
I think it's hilarious but I'm going to
to guest star as guardian who is in
prison voluntarily it looks like I love
when they broke him out he was just like
okay let's do it
he literally opened the bars as if it
was just a door they've kind of
explained this in the Thor movies like
the difference in the physiology between
as Guardians and humans as Guardians
typically live about 5,000 years they're
not like celestial beings or anything
like that they're just highly evolved
human oit's that live on a different
plane their physiology is also a lot
more resilient so they heal wounds a lot
faster
that's why Loki is able to eat a blast
from the destroyer gun and not die now
they captured him during season two but
I liked his performance this season
better it just is a little more
tongue-in-cheek
does just a little more comedy he really
likes living on earth so he's gonna just
trying to hide out not make too much
noise that's why he doesn't try to kill
Coulson the first chance he gets just
because he just wants to be left alone
just to have his fun most of the
scientific concepts they mentioned
during his scenes were references to
Thor movies like the einstein-rosen
bridge that's the Rainbow Bridge
speaking of which number one WTF moment
they get Simmons back after realizing
that the monolith is a doorway to
another planet on the other side of the
universe we're all asking the exact same
question here what is the planet that
Simmons was sent to is that Morag isn't
another creat outpost is it something
we're gonna see during guardians of the
galaxy what I'll say right now is is I
definitely do not think that it is at
tool and I think that it is just another
create post no I do not think that we'll
see this planet specifically mentioned
during guardians of the galaxy too but I
do think that they will find out where
it is on the show after they came back
the monolith exploded that's just to let
you know that they're not just gonna be
jumping back and forth between planets
all the time why then would the writers
send Simmons away to another planet in
the hiatus and then bring her back so
fast like what you know what's the point
if they're bringing her back so fast
on the surface what I think is going on
is that they just want to incorporate
the timeless nature of the Inhumans
they're an ancient Kree experiment that
they abandoned eons ago but they left
their equipment lying around it's still
worked so people continue to use it so
the Inhumans continue to evolve on their
own sheltered from humanity so I think
last season Jang's Inhumans colony is
just the beginning I think that we'll
learn a lot more about in human society
not
the royal family mind you I don't I
don't people see any royal family
members to the Inhumans movie which is
years and years away I don't think we're
gonna see ATS land but I do think that
we'll hear about it we've gotten a taste
of Crete outpost I think they're just
like slowly raising that bar eventually
we'll probably learn that lash comes
from another group of Inhumans
so you know maybe mid season finale
maybe second half of the season we'll
learn about them he wasn't really
present in this episode but I think
they're just laying the groundwork to
explain where he comes from and why he's
doing what he's doing like why he's
going around killing all these new
Inhumans but I'm so happy that Simmons
and Fitz are together again I feel like
they work best when they're together if
you remember last season it was all
about Fitz trying to survive his trauma
now it's all about Simmons trying to
survive her trauma so where Simmons was
trying to help Fitz last season now it's
gonna be the other way around some of
you have asked me if I think that
Simmons is an inhuman I actually do
think that she has inhuman DNA in her
but I don't know that the show will ever
take her through terrigenesis the crazy
thing about the Asgardian is is that he
didn't seem to have any kind of idea
what activated the monolith I think that
it's activated by people with inhuman
DNA but let me know in the comments that
planet that Simmons went to do you think
that that is where lash is from and do
you think that we're gonna see another
monolith somewhere on earth this season
but the episode was great I still keep
expecting them to raise their game I
think it's gonna get even better it's
the same with air on the flash - you
know vastly better than they were in
previous seasons just to kind of move
things into Marvel movie territory and I
know I haven't done a Marvel movie video
in a little while but Marvel just
confirmed that ant-man
2 is gonna be ant-man and the wasp
that's gonna be the title it's gonna
drop July 6 2018 I know that's it's like
a long ways off but they're just
confirming that it's gonna be a thing
Evangeline Lilly will be in full battle
attire just expect them to tweak the
costume from the end of ant-man like if
you saw the post-credits scene with the
wasp suit just expect them to tweak that
a little bit they also announced a
couple of untitled movies even further
out than that
now here's what I think is going on
they're probably just clearing space for
a Captain Marvel sequel in case that's
successful and a Hulk movie if they get
the distribution rights back from
Universal now the reason that you
haven't seen a solo hoch film yet is not
because Marvel doesn't want to do it
they definitely want to do another Hulk
film especially because Mark Ruffalo so
Universal still holds the distribution
rights for Hulk films and that's kind of
like an indefinite thing there's no end
date on that Disney is like one of the
largest film distribution companies in
the world they don't need anyone else to
release their films so they don't want
to give away a giant chunk of the
profits to other companies so they're
not gonna release another Hulk film
until they get the distribution rights
back so when you're thinking about these
untitled movies just think about sequels
to the brand-new movies that are coming
out like you have Doctor Strange they're
probably clearing paths for a Doctor
Strange sequel should it happen and I
definitely think it will here's a good
question for you guys though they have
Doctor Strange and Captain Marvel and
then now like the wasp and ant-man
coming back who else do you guys want to
see them introduce in the Marvel
Universe I know we all want to see she
hook we want to see Spider Woman but I
don't think they're gonna do she-hulk
until they do another solo Hulk film and
I don't think that they're gonna do
Spider Woman until the new spider-man
franchise launches and has proven
successful which I definitely think it
will be but we can talk more about
future Marvel films in another video so
be sure to subscribe to get everything I
have an arrow flash Q&A that I'm gonna
be posting next and there's a couple of
trailer videos so I might shuffle those
around just a little bit
we finally got a Jessica Jones teaser
with some purple man in it so I actually
you know what I might do that next just
because I'm doing this Marvel video
right now white guys wait for all that
stuff to post you can click here for
last night's episode of arrow if you
guys haven't seen that video yet and you
can click here for all my Jessica Jones
trailer videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you